[Musique]
oui
ans
on
[Musique]
le marois c'est un fromage d'appellation
d'origine
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire qu'ils répondent à des usages
loyaux et constant c'est un fromage que
je n'ai pas inventé mais j'ai simplement
le mérite de reprendre ses traditions et
de les continuer et donc
il obéit à certains critères il doit
être fabriqué dans une zone géographique
précise dire que le lait doit être
collectées dans cette zone le fromage
transformer dans les maisons et affine
également dans la zone il doit son
origine à l'abbaye de maroilles où il ya
plus de 1000 angle les moines affiné
déjà ce fromage il a donc un passé une
histoire c'est un fromage authentique
qui a ses lettres de noblesse
c'est donc un fromage à pâte molle et
croûte a été fabriqué à partir de lait
de vache essentiellement ce sont des
race la race laitière c'est la race
française frisonne pie noir donc on
procède à une collecte régulière délais
il y as en présure âge du lait travail
du cai et [ __ ] égouttage moulage
salage et on obtient le maroilles blanc
se dire un produit brut
à ce stade-là le fromage doit pas encore
deux coups c'est un bloc de deux cahiers
et c'est seulement l'affinage qui va
donner ses caractéristiques au produit
ensuite deuxième stade le passage en à
loire ou le fromage va se couvrir d'une
légère moisissures naturel qui pousse
naturellement et qui est destiné à
préparer le terrain pour le
développement des ferments du rouge
après ce passage à la loire le fromage
est descendu en cave et c'est vraiment
de l'affinage proprement dit c'est toute
cette période d'affinage enquête qui va
donner ses caractéristiques au produit
dans l'histoire en cave commence donc
par un premier brossage un premier
lavage pour enlever les moisissures qui
se sont développées et progressivement
vous avez la pariser de l'apparition des
ferments du rouge qui donne une
coloration de plus en plus foncé au fur
et à mesure que se fait la finale qui
est une coloration tout à fait naturel
se livra ya aucun colorant que ce soit
dans la pâte à l'extérieur
la coloration de la croûte est dû
simplement aux effets des ferments du
rouge dans cette cave vous avez la
préparation des vieux lille le vieux
lille qu'elle que c'est au départ c'est
donc un maroilles blanc et qui va être
affiné traité différemment le premier
traitement consiste à salé une deuxième
preuve le produit est elle a disposé sur
des planches des planches ou des tapis
afin de favoriser la pousse du grand il
se développe sur le format du vieux
lille rappelle vieux-lille où guy donc
une demande qui est très différente
acres otages qui est très différent du
maroilles alors que le maroilles vous
avez une teinte blonde rouge où sont
rangés sur le vieux lille c'est une
teinte qui est beaucoup plus gris c'est
pas du tout là on dit viol il parce que
c'est d'origine lilloise ou non c'est en
fait c'est le lieu de consommation qui a
donné le nom au conduit d'accord alors
en fait pourquoi il y a le ses dérivés
le viol il parce que c'est dû aux
problèmes qu autrefois il y avait pas de
frigo il n'y avait pas de moyens
modernes de transport de conservation
des produits
il fallait donc envisager quelque chose
pour prolonger l'affinage faciliter son
transport et c'était le sel justement
qui permettait de celles qui donnent un
peu secoué qui permet de prolonger la
finale parce que la finale j'ai
carrément doublé il faut un vieux lille
pour qu'il soit bien fait il faut trois
à quatre mois
il peut sauvegarder 3 4 points il ya
d'autres fromages qui sont oui alors
vous avez le dauphin le dauphin
maroilles une fan de maroilles avec des
herbes l'estragon en particulier et le
poivre pourquoi le dauphin parce que
c'est le nom va du fromage a été parce
qu'ils étaient fabriqués en l'honneur du
dauphin de roy qui passait dans la
région alors il ya d'autres spécialités
dérivées du maroilles avec des pattes
plus douces comme le coeur d'avesnes le
carré d'avesnes voilà essentiellement la
famille des fromages de l'avesnois bien
fermiers vous diriger ce restaurant avec
votre femme yolande qui va nous préparer
une tarte au maroilles fameuse tarte au
maroilles qui est une spécialité de
l'avesnois avant même de commencer je
voudrais vous demander d'où vient à
l'utilisation de plus en plus fréquente
du fromage dans les plats cuisinés band
une peur parce que ici dans cette région
c'est une région d'herbage donc attendu
sur les tiers qui est le dérivé le
premier dérivés bien sûr le fromage et
l'utilisation des produits locaux nous
permet justement d'extrapoler un petit
peu cette production laitière en
fonction de divers d'utilisation tout en
essayant de faire comprendre aux gens et
aux gourmets et aux gastronomes à la
fois qu'elle ce fromage a une origine au
départ assez démocratique et qui
maintenant c'est de plus en plus
sophistiquées au niveau des utilisations
diverses
la production de ce fromage nous permet
de faire
beaucoup de plats à base de pâte
d'où les pattes brisées feuilleter
levées hormis les pâtes sucre et bien
sûr mais la flamiche étant la plus
connue et se maroilles dont on parle
beaucoup de plus en plus a réussi à
créer des simulations culinaires et des
émanations différente au niveau des
côtes de porc avesnoise des escalopes
maroillaise d'ego hier qui est un petit
peu une émulation de valenciennes mais
surtout veut pratiquer dans l'avesnois
avec cette richesse du fromage que vous
tenez c'est maintenant et qui a amené
pas mal de personnes dans cette région
et surtout des nationaux mais aussi des
cuisiniers yolande carlier vous allez
maintenant de présenter une tarte au
maroilles pas précisément une tarte au
maroilles c'est une création que mon
mari - vous préparez vous donc pour
votre émission qui est un peu rapport
avec les tartes tatin si vous voulez
dont c'était une tête retournée que nous
nous faisons une pâte brisée que nous
recouvrons par la suite au dessus de
l'appareil de ma fait la différence
entre une tarte normal le fait que ce
soir corrèze lé recouverte et puis
souffler vous appelez ça comment le
total de marmagne totalement une
création que nous innovons on a une main
commenceront donc je vous préparez donc
cette pâte brisée qui consiste à 250 g
de farine il passait de sel 125 g de
beurre mou bien sûr je commence à
mélanger le tout est plutôt que de l'eau
je mets du lait d'accord pour ma patte
en matière de verre de lait
chose qu'on fait généralement selon ses
propos buner oui mais on peut la
travailler tout de suite après avoir
laisser reposer la pâte pendant une
heure vous l'avez placé dans un moule
tout en gardant une partie pour ouvrir
diverses l'a découvert qu'ils avaient
découvert dont je vais vous préparez
l'appareil qui seront consiste à du
maroilles du fromage blanc et d eux
commencent par les d eux un peu de
poivre et sel en baisse ou l'ensemble
aussi à 300 g de fromage blanc fromage
blanc sarah quoi de mon existence qui
n'est pas celui ranger dans sa valise et
l'apprentissage
non j'ai joué mes 200 g de maroilles
couper en petits dés
voilà et on verse sur la pente sur la
pâte mais on va placer le couvert enfin
pas sûr que vers ce qui va donner ce
résultat d'accords donc 1 2 jaunes
d'oeufs battus oui que nous étalons au
pinceau pour dorer un peu d'accord est
au four et au four une demi heure une
demi heure à four moyen
voilà donc après une demi heure de
cuisson oui j'en veux notre totale de
maroilles riquet bien souffler
finalement le couvercle sert à garder le
parfum de l'appareil ce qui fait la
différence entre une tarte de mormal
normal oui et puis crs bien point de
l'intérieur nous avons parlé et produits
locaux est ici tous mes collègues
restaurateurs en tue la gentillesse
d'apporter une conclusion qui l'aurait
bien personnel on a devant nous la tarte
à la rhubarbe qui a été présentée par
monsieur jean lain hubière c'est bien
sage en un espace et une tarte au
maroilles qui a été réalisé par
messieurs looten balès et berthier c'est
pourquoi la tarte est assez conséquent
concert avec le cancer a lancé on s'est
permis de la mariée avec un saint
nicolas de bourgueil et un chino
d'accord voilà ici des des petits choux
farcis de fromage dans l'esprit fromage
de maroilles réalisé par monsieur
mathieu notre fameuse moment brisé par
notre président d'honneur qui ne donne à
une petite note viril dans notre
avesnois avait des assaisonnements bien
particulier
monsieur coûte lui et nous avons envie
un poulet au marois avait tout d'une
garniture quand vous voyez une petite
terrine aux trois légumes
monsieur mener à tout à fait une tarte à
la rhubarbe avec une meringue souffler
il ne tente un an va être recouvert de
crème fraîche en pâte sucrée ici est la
composition de notre ami chevallier
chinoise monte avec rose d'hector en
cacao et une chinoise font légère
parfumée à quoi christian ude aux
pruneaux mousse de pruneaux ça c'est une
double composition de monsieur le vert
puisque là on a fait une pâtisserie avec
des fruits qui sont encore un peu des
primeurs puisque d'esprit on n'a pas
encore bien il y en a beaucoup en pleurs
et puis des poires la marmite avesnoise
et reese et par monsieur qu'une chez son
chef
una vez de nougatine monté sur un sorbet
tous nous travaillons dans la promotion
de cette région avec moise et peu
d'entre nous tous sommes avesnois mais
néanmoins on s'est tous mis à l'unisson
[Musique]
on